Christie rode in David what is the most
unethical thing that you've been asked
to do by your employer I don't have that
many stories for this because I've been
working for myself for so long at this
point but I think the most unethical
thing I was ever asked to do was sell
extended service plans when I worked at
Circuit City and pretend that they were
a good deal we had this whole shtick
when I worked at Circuit City the
now-defunct Circuit City where we would
say listen you've probably heard a lot
about extended warranties extended
warranties only extend the manufacturer
warranty which is really not that good
what Circuit City offers is an extended
service plan this is a completely
different service and it's actually
backed by General Electric which was
true so even if Circuit City goes out of
business you still have your service
plan because it's backed by GE
and G's not going to go out of business
let me talk to you a little bit about
what it covers that the manufacturer
warranty doesn't cover a blah blah blah
blah blah I remember it like it was
yesterday even though it's been 14 years
since I ever sold an extended service
plan and it was bogus I mean these these
were not necessary plans they were often
so overpriced like I remember on a
$1,600 laptop that was the big boy
service plan and we made like 15%
Commission off of these service plans I
think the service plan was four hundred
and thirty dollars for four years so as
a salesperson I was like oh I make 60
bucks I make 20 office selling the
laptop but I make 60 from selling the
service plan or whatever so we were
hugely incentivized to sell these I
probably drank some of the kool-aid and
thought listen they wouldn't really be
offering a crappy service plan if it
didn't have some value right so I
rationalized it in my mind as being a
really good thing it was very convenient
how I did it and I did make money off of
it it was probably I think close to half
of my income at Circuit City was from
selling these service plans Wow and I
think that that's probably the most
immoral thing and I have never bought an
extended warranty since I don't buy
extended warranties when I lease a car I
don't buy them on any electronic device
and at this point I always go through
the same thought process in my head if I
add up all the warranties I've never
purchased and compare that to how many
of my devices have actually broken I'm
I'm thousands of dollars ahead that even
if something breaks and I have to
full replacement cost it's still cheaper
than if I had bought a warranty on
everything all along guess it depends on
how well you treat your stuff though
like what if you're super klutzy then
maybe it is worth it together it
happened to me once when I was running
on a treadmill and my phone at the time
I didn't even have a case or a screen
protector on it it fell off and fell
right on a corner on the treadmill and
the screen was smashed and I ended up oh
yeah I ended up paying I think it was
175 bucks cash only on Canal Street
Chinatown New York City that's a whole
other story for another day and I got it
fixed but the hundred and seventy five
was still way less than I would have
been paying on warranties on my TV and
my previous cell phone and my laptop and
my car and all of this stuff so I don't
do it any stories from Domino's well
it's interesting you point out Domino's
I would so I was thinking maybe you
wouldn't want me to answer this question
no I believe me I want you to answer we
won't talk about the scenario that
happened back in March then no don't
mention the thing from March absolutely
absolutely never want to hear about that
but do you have any story any weird
qualities from Domino's and to be clear
Domino's is mostly franchises whatever
Pat's about to say and I don't know what
it is and it might be nothing is not an
attack on the corporation of Domino's
because these were all decisions made at
the local franchise yeah the franchisee
or the business owner the general
manager someone he wanted me to lend my
car to one of the employees there
because they had a very limited amount
of drivers and they wanted someone else
in the time that I was like going off to
college or whatever yeah someone else to
use my car while you were gone while I
was gone oh that's an exam Oh would it
be it would be a big favor to us if Neil
could borrow your car for a few months
while you're off at college we're you
did you do deliveries or you just were
working at the location no I made the
pizzas oh is the debauchery in its own
range yeah yeah how and where you
weren't vegan at the time no okay
hopefully not so they say let this other
guy who were calling Neil borrow your
car and it wasn't just like while you're
cooking it was while you're away at
college leave your car for Neil to make
deliveries with it I mean I guess the
assumption would just be for deliveries
right but how am I gonna know whatever
he wants and you didn't do it I hope I
don't know that it's a lack of ethics it
wouldn't have been unethical in other
words you weren't really being asked to
do anything unethical
it would just be really stupid to give
the car that you're paying for insurance
on and depreciation on to someone to
some other 17 year old kid to use for
deliveries I would think it is unethical
because it's almost like he's trying to
coerce me in a certain way I don't know
not even a legal adult at that age I'm
saying it's definitely unethical for you
to be asked to do that but right I felt
that the selling of the service plans
was me doing something unethical you
letting someone borrow your car I did
nothing wrong you you wouldn't have been
doing anything wrong but I think that an
employer putting you in that position is
pretty unethical yeah